hey Kevin Frazier yeah how are you doing
how are you handling things it's it's
been a while now I know but Kevin is
just it just seems an ongoing ongoing
ongoing progression of just sadness but
I you know I'm starting to feel a little
lighter because I'm really encouraged
really encouraged by the diversity of
the protesters by the length of the
protesters and that twelve thirteen days
out people are still in the streets
because they know there is still so much
work to be done and I do get
encouragement from that but on the
backdrop on the top of that though we're
still mourning the death of horrible
death that we all witnessed with our own
eyes of George Floyd and I'm still
haunted by that I'm still so upset glad
I'm so sorry I'm still so upset by that
last story where the man is handcuffed
underneath a car where people are
pleading please he can't breathe and
we're watching a man die so we go from
that story now to this story where she
falsely accused as a black man on
television I mean I I don't even know
what to do or how to handle this at this
particular time yeah and it comes on the
on the back of Brianna Taylor about
Albrecht and so many others that have
been killed at the hands of police tell
me about the special tonight well I'm
really excited about the special Kevin
the team at CBS has pulled this together
I would say in four days max maybe it's
even three you've got 60 minutes
producers 48 hours producers CBS this
morning's producers all-hands-on-deck
working on this special and I think
we're not I think I know we're covering
a wide variety of issues I have an
interview with amadou diallo smother you
remember that story back in 1999 four
twenty three year old son was shot by
police police fired 41 shots when he was
reaching for a wallet and interent they
thought it was a gun so imagine what
she's thinking from 1999 to 2020 and we
are still having that conversation she
was really good I'm talking to the
Central Park birder
you remember him and his sister who was
the one that released a video who said
this could have gone another way and my
brother could have been George Floyd
they are very powerful she was going to
tap into
a deep deep dark vein of racism of
racial bias that runs through this
country and has for centuries talking to
two authors who you know more and more
people Kevin want to read books about
race they are in the top five at a
publisher say to me the other day that
in 20 years of publishing he has never
seen so many people that are buying
books about racial issues Norah
O'Donnell has an interview with Joe
Biden talking about the times I mean we
we I think we have covered every single
base so it's not just a rehash of things
you already know we're going to take
we're trying to take steps looking
forward what does it mean where do we go
from here
and I'm really really proud of it and I
can't wait for people to see it tonight
listen Kevin I can't wait to see it meet
myself they're still edit again they are
still adding it up even as we speak
that's what's making me emotional that
his last words were mom mama you know it
just goes to the but this is what's
getting me it goes to the primal
instinct that we all have because your
mother is your ultimate protector and
his mother died two years ago yeah you
got a little choked up when you were
talking about will in the conversation
you had yeah tell me about that well
listen you know you always I think when
times like this and I'm sure you have
the same you have you you know what it's
like to have a black son I mean I now
worry about will who's 33 years old
walking his friggin dog in the
neighborhood you know because I think
everybody is on such a hair-trigger
these days and you know I don't want my
son your son or anybody's son really to
be part of a national conversation where
their pictures shown nationwide and
everybody knows their name in the
circumstances where they're done but
statistics do show that more unarmed men
are killed by police officers than any
other group and that is very frightening
to me so you know choked me up because
it's still going on and I but I think
maybe just maybe and I know we've heard
this before I even said to well well I
feel this is different I said this feels
different to me this looks different to
me he said you know what I'll believe
it's different when it's different
because right now it isn't different
well you know I feel a little more
optimistic than that but he does raise a
very good point you know things this
isn't the first time we've seen a man an
unarmed man killed by the police
it's not the first time but George Floyd
is different to me because we watched it
from beginning to end and he had watched
the callousness of how the police
officer did it you know in other videos
there was a lot of action a lot going on
what are you really looking at there was
a struggle this man was not struggling
and we watched that and we watched the
officer seeming not to care that he was
being filmed as he says he put his knee
on George Floyd's neck for 8 minutes and
46 seconds that to me is different we
all watched it and I think for many
white people in the audience it was a
wake-up call you know what else is
encouraging the age of the protesters
are young and many of these young white
kids young white adults are calling
their parents to say huh and they're
questioning their parents about some of
their views I'm very encouraged by that
these are kids who grew up with Barack
Obama as their president in a different
time I also think that it is important
that we know that you and Oprah are
leading conversations about this about
what is going on in this country did you
have a chance to talk and have you guys
had a chance to talk about this yeah you
know Kevin this is funny
because I was talking here I said you
know CBS is gonna be doing a primetime
special about that she goes I'm doing a
primetime special - I go when's your on
time special she said Tuesday when's
yours I said Tuesday what time is your
fine time special well mine is at 10:00
and hers is at 9:00 so people can watch
both or they can record one and watch it
in the later time but listen Oprah and I
aren't the only one talking about this
everybody is having this conversation
and there's a hunger Kevin there is a
hunger for information about this and
that to me is very satisfying and very
gratifying so I say the more people that
are listening the more more educated
people can be the better off we all are
I know this is the first special but it
feels like this could morph into
something because people all over the
world and people especially in this
country want to know so much so that
this is opening the conversation and
they
this lays the grounds for something that
is regular you know people think about a
show like Nightline was birthed out of
the IROC devices so maybe this is
getting of something yeah this is listen
this is not the end we're not going to
do one special and then say done you
know the funeral of George Floyd as you
know is today the burial whether there
admit this will be the last of he said
one two three services so today is the
burial and I often think that when you
lose a loved one
you really can't begin to grieve and
mourn until they are buried you know you
have so many things that you have to do
to prepare for the service so I think
for them this is a new step in what
they're going to have to do for us I'm
very heartened that the fact that after
the three other officers were charged I
have somebody said to me Kevin well the
three other officers were charged what
more do what more did people want and I
just thought to myself oh you poor maybe
you don't even kind of get it it's
really just the beginning of
conversation because there's a lot of
work to be done so this is not the end
of a conversation you're right Kevin
this is the beginning of the
conversation because there is a lot of
stuff to digest sort out and correct
here and go
it can't be lost with the significance
of you being in that chair for CBS right
now in the importance of it that people
may not have seen they're like oh this
is Gail and it's you know yeah but it's
also important that you aren't there as
an african-american woman to be able to
tell these stories in a nuanced way well
you know I always say Kevin when I sit
on the set of CBS news that I have a
front-row seat to history and and it
doesn't feel it feels more important now
than ever before because I do think
sometimes the conversation is very
nuanced and I do think it's important to
point out different things that people
might not have noticed before I just
know my presence in being in a meeting
to be honest with you to point out
certain things why don't we cover X Y &
Z has anybody thought of reaching out to
bla bla bla bla listen we have a really
great team but that's why it is
important to have diversity at the table
wherever your table is and so I feel
very blessed and very honored
have one of those seats but I'm telling
you listen it takes a team it takes a
village CBS is not tone deaf we have a
lot of smart people there and I'm very
proud of what you're going to see
tonight I'm excited
well Oh magazine also do something yeah
of course yeah we've been working on
that and we have Oh magazine digital we
have Oprah Magazine calm Arianna Davis
who's our social director no we are all
over of course Oprah Magazine
70-something and has it been weird not
getting to see yes Kevin yes listen my
favorite son wills in California
favorite daughter Kirby's in California
Oprah's in California yes it's been very
difficult because the people I who are
closest to live there and I just sent
over the other day I just said you know
I've been in my home what if I did the
news from your guest house is that an
option Mull that over and she said yes I
could come so believe me I am thinking
about that I'm thinking about that I
have to see how much longer this goes on
but it's now going into month number
three I thought we'd be here maybe a
month maybe maybe six weeks but yeah I'm
getting I'm starting to feel how shall
we say the wear and the tear and the
wear and tear and the heaviness of it it
doesn't weighs on me I cannot sleep I
feel a constant state of worry and angst
I mean listen we went from kovin the
pandemic of Kovac which by the way
people is still going on please don't
think that because they're relaxing the
rules that this is an over we are still
very much in the middle of this pandemic
so working with that and now dealing
with the horrible murder of George Floyd
and all the repercussions of that it's a
lot so yeah I do feel a little a little
stress just a tad stressed yeah yeah
well we appreciate you and I appreciate
you being out front doing this cuz it's
gonna wait to see it tonight okay yeah
I'm excited
we're very proud of it Kevin I can't
stress that enough
[Music]